es que preocupa la situación en colombia
juana y reacciones en diferentes
sectores del mundo del deporte que es lo
que dicen ha sido un día en el que las
grandes voces del deporte de colombiano
han expresado su rechazo hacia los
abusos de derechos humanos y su
preocupación por lo que ocurre en el
país cafetero uno de ellos el futbolista
radamel falcao garcía quien hizo un
llamado a la no violencia y pidió
respetar la manifestación pacífica jaime
rodríguez otro capitán de la selección
colombiana dijo textualmente nos están
matando
yoreli rincón futbolista del inter de
milán compartió la imagen al revés de la
bandera colombiana un símbolo
internacional de pedido de ayuda fuera
del fútbol se expresaron mariana pajón
la doble campeona olímpica de bmx la
piloto está tiene a calderón y también
en bernal el campeón del tour de francia
en 2019 el corredor de liniers